Why is honey okay? So is honey okay to use as a sweetener?
Well, it's better than using sugar. So why is honey better than sugar? Well, there's lots of reasons. So honey could self
has
qualities that could be beneficial for your immune system.
Honey has qualities
that are that are much lower glycemic index. We didn't won't break down into glucose nearly as fast as other things.
Honey is has
You could go into a lot of beneficial qualities of honey that it can be actually good for us. So
Now I'm not again, you still have cancer and it's still ultimately going to be broken down into glucose.
So if you're on a ketogenic diet, well then honey is out of the question, but if you're not on a ketogenic diet
and you want a sweetener for something, honey is probably your best choice of sweetener
because of those other beneficial qualities. But again,
remember too much of a good thing. It's bad thing too. So it's all about balance.
You certainly don't want to be just spiky your glucose by telling honey thinking that that's good now.
So I'm just going to hold you on that. So ultimately
what breaks down to the glucose can feed cancer. So because that, you know,
cancer cells rely on glycolysis and the end point of glycolysis for
metabolism. So you have to be careful with it. So all about balance.